So, now what we're seeing
are what I call interfaces.
Each of the components that I just
mentioned, exports some interface,
which explains to the client
of that component, or
the outside world, how to interact with
it, what capabilities it provides.
In our case, those capabilities
are what we call predicates.
You can think of them as
tables in a database.
These are predicates, or
tables, that are accessible and
visible to the outside world that
clients could query or update.
And as you see here, even though we
have four different kinds of components,
we only have two different kinds of
interfaces forecast and multipliers, and
this is by design.
What that means is that I can,
as you see in this example,
I can have multiple components
that implement the same interface.
Now what's nice about that
is components that implement
the same interface are plug compatible,
and layered assemblies.
So I can actually build different
assemblies that use each of these
components, each of these three forecast
components that I've just declared.
Put them together in different ways and
build a nice,
rich library of variance,
just by putting those forecasts,
just by putting those
together in different ways.
>> And can you relate this
use of the term interface to
its use in other languages like Java?
>> Yes it's almost exactly the same use.
So in Java interfaces you declare
signatures of methods that
many different objects would, obviously
many different classes could implement.
It's essentially the same thing here.